is there as a big story right big
storyline between all this movie started
movie and the next ones yes there is
that what we call is the arc of the
character you know um there is still a
lot of room for Peter Parker and
spider-man especially to grow in the
next two movies you know he's definitely
not the finished article by the end of
spider-man homecoming and I really look
forward to exploring the different ways
that you can grow up and go through
puberty I guess and yeah it's gonna be
an exciting couple movies and you said
two movies it means I'm coming two and
three oh yeah there'll be spider-man 2
and three it won't be homecoming three
and most is Cooper because we knew her
but the second one but not the third one
yeah well now you know when you come on
the set with a 50 or 60 superheroes how
was it it was surreal man you know um
when I made Civil War because I
obviously came on to the process very
late I didn't really get the chance to
meet everyone and work with everyone
properly but now on Avengers I am having
that opportunity and it's everything I
could have ever dreamed of you know as a
kid and a fan it really is a wonderful
place to be in a wonderful work
environment and I'm very honored to be a
part of it
hey everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of news spider-man far from home
to talk about Tom Hall and always doing
stuff like this but there have only been
a couple times that they've referred to
the actual trilogy that they have
planned with his character for the solo
movies so I broke this all down like a
top 10 list there's a new round of that
spider-man ps4 game giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this number 10 important to note that
the trilogy that he's referring to in
this interview here does not include
Avengers infinity war Avengers 4 Marvel
and Sony only signed a contract for five
films that includes Captain America
Civil War spider-man Home Coming
Avengers infinity war Avengers 4 in
spider-man far from home 9 that means
that they already had planned a trilogy
when they signed Tom Holland not really
big surprise there you know shocking
twists big Hollywood studio wants to
turn their franchise their
billion-dollar 4
Chai's into a trilogy why then was Kevin
Feige only talking about all the five
films that they had on their contract
with marble so eight this is the actual
quote that he gave originally in the way
that the events of civil war directly
informed the opening of homecoming and
this state of mind as he goes back to
high school so too will the events of
the next two Avengers movies as he
continues with high school
this original 22 movie arc ends with the
untitled Avengers in May of 2019 and
then two months later it will be Peter
and spider-man that usher us into the
aftermath of how things proceed from
there so spider-man is a cornerstone for
how they set up Marvel phase four so
obviously this is sort of tipping you
off that they never planned on stopping
it's spider-man far from why then has
Kevin Feige not talked more about them
doing more films with spider-man after
this current sharing arrangement in that
number seven I think the reason is is
because of trilogy fatigue because
they've done that with the last two
spider-man trilogies they want to
distance themselves from that and say
that this version of spider-man is very
different that's why they're doing all
the different characters like the
vulture Mysterio people that you've
never seen before in live-action but
it's also Marvel and Sony or Disney and
Sony not trying to put the cart before
the horse six Tom Holland talks about
Peter Parker's arc through this
spider-man trilogy what is that story
besides you know full-blown sinister six
tag-teaming him in that third film is
really about him learning to be able to
strategize on the fly and defeat all of
his enemies with a little help from his
friends like Ned leads in the chair the
Avengers
maybe also Michelle now since they've
completely rewritten the Mary Jane
Watson role within the spider-man movie
universe all the footage we've been
seeing of her and spider-man swinging
around Penn Station outside in the
absolute chill that she seems to have
about it implies that she's almost part
of the inner circle if she hasn't
already learned his secret identity by
whatever this point in the movie is
number five the Washington Monument of
spider-man character development he
start out in homecoming in civil war and
he's sort of like Iron Man's stark tech
intern he graduates to full-blown
Avenger during infinity war four that
means spider-man far from home is him
getting his master's degree in being a
superhero
multiple new suits within a single movie
way higher number than the first two we
saw during homecoming in infinity war
what's the next evolution of what we've
seen him do so far he started out in
civil war as this dumpster diver that
cobbled together his own web-shooters so
whereas in homecoming he had this
blueprint for how to be a hero laid out
for him by Ironman and it came with a
literal instruction manual aka suit lady
Karen part of the idea I think with this
special Nick Fury black shield suit is
that he's forced to do some of those
things without suit lady there to help
him like he has to learn to operate on
the fly without a big safety net the
iron spider suit in infinity war
literally acts like a safety net
catching him before he falls into
Earth's orbit the brand-new Steve Ditko
classic redesign we've seen in all the
footage of him might genuinely be
something that he helps create or modify
if it's just the stark tech suit that
he's then added a bunch of changes to
it's him taking a more active role in
his character development you kind of
saw that during infinity war in
homecoming when he tried to stop the
vulture like I need to stop this weapon
sighs the last film in this spider-man
trilogy would be like him getting his
PhD thesis in superhero you know however
they fit home into the title coming home
is still my top pick right now but I've
seen a lot of funny suggestions so he
now has his own team of friends it seems
like Michelle is gonna be stepping up it
might be a more active member it would
be him learning to take down the
villains with minimal help from the
Avengers by the time I think we get to
the third spider-man film it'll be Peter
doing everything by himself with a
little bit of help from maybe people
like Sheree like giving him some tips on
style but for the most part it's still
Peter Parker doing everything by himself
three if all the sinister six teasers
they've been dropping are just big mr. X
and they're trying to mislead us and
they've always intended on doing
something different what is that third
film in the trilogy are they gonna try
and do some crazy shattered Dimensions
thing because of all the multiverse
stuff that's happening during Avengers 4
or are they gonna try to do something
simpler just because they spent so much
time setting up sinister 6 in that
homecoming post-credit scene because of
all the confirmed sinister six members
that are in far from home and a couple
additional rumored ones it still feels
like they're headed for an MCU version
of that team remember the cancelled
sinister 6 movie The Drew Goddard was
going to make during the Andrew
era for Sony recently in an interview he
said that he felt like that movie could
still happen at some point the way was
originally pitched though is that it
would be more of a spin-off movie
Thunderbolt style with the villains the
Spider Man just played a part in but
largely it would be told from the
perspective of those sinister six
characters so wouldn't be just a
straight-up Spider Man sequel but the
only reason I think that Sony hasn't
tried to announce a sinister six movie
because they've announced almost every
big character movie that they could
venom Kraven the hunter all these are
the weird obscure characters why
wouldn't they do a sinister six movie
and I think that is because they have an
arrangement with Marvel to bookmark that
property for future MCU use too though
if you're really pessimistic I know
chances of Sony walking away from their
deal with Marvel after the last film on
the contract which is spider-man far
from home Amy Pascal and Kevin Feige
seem to have a really great working
relationship she's been very
self-deprecating about all the funny
interviews that they've done and how she
always steps over her words and just
kind of waits for Kevin Feige to clarify
what it is their grand design is but
have you been following the news Sony's
still lost a whole bunch of money last
financial quarter the venom movie did
well recently and I do think that Sony
wants to try and get Tom Holland into
that venom verse just to legitimize it a
little bit more but the good thing about
the success of venom is is it it doesn't
put more pressure on Sony to try and
cram Tom Hollands spider-man into those
films so I wouldn't worry too much about
that but let me know in the comments
below what do you want them to do with
that third film in the trilogy there's
that new Kathryn Langford Avengers 4
video that I'm working on there's also a
new flash episode posting later tonight
so I'll try to get everything out as
fast as possible no worries
congratulations to the giveaway winner
for my last big Marvel video Budokai
elite 2018 please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here for that new
black costume teaser and click here to
learn about the secret Deadpool
Christmas movie and Deadpool during
Marvel phase 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]